WE'VE GOT THE NUMBERS BUT WILL
BRING YOU THAT INVESTIGATION AND
JUST A MINUTE.
FIRST TONIGHT, AFTER 200 YEARS,
THE DEMOCRATS WERE A POLITICAL
PARTY WITH CONVENTIONAL
POLITICAL GOALS.
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS NOW A
RELIGIOUS CULT WITH ALL THAT
EMPLOYED.
DISSENT HAS BEEN BANNED.
ANYONE WHO QUESTIONS THE PARTIES
VISORS LEFT FRINGE IS DENOUNCED
AS A RACIST HERETIC, THE PARTIES
DESCENDANT INTO A PURITY SPIRAL,
AND NOBODY IS SAFE, NOT EVEN THE
PARTY'S SPEAKERS.
NANCY PELOSI, THE MOST LEFT-WING
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
FIRE-BREATHING LIBERAL FOR
LONGER THAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ HAS BEEN ALIVE.
NONE OF THAT HAS BEEN ABLE TO
SAVE HER.
OCASIO-CORTEZ AND A TINY GROUP
OF HOUSE FRESHMAN DEMAND
EXPLICIT SOCIALISM IN THIS
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
THEY WANT TO OPEN THE BORDERS,
ABOLISH THE PRISONS, AND COMMAND
THE U.S. ECONOMY IN THE NAME OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
PLUS HE HAS CONTEMPT OF THEIR
TOTAL IGNORANCE OF HOW LAWS ARE
MADE.
SHE HAS EXPRESSED THAT CONTENT
IN PUBLIC AND INCLUDING HERE.
>> SHE LIKES TO MINIMIZE THE
CONFLICT WITHIN HER CAUCUS,
BETWEEN THE MODERATES AND THE
PROGRESSIVES.
YOU HAVE THESE WINGS, AOC AND
HER GROUP ON ONE SIDE --
>> Tucker: FOR SAYING THINGS
LIKE THAT, PELOSI TONIGHT IS
FACING A REVOLT FROM WITHIN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SHE IS BEING DENOUNCED.
GUESS WHAT THEY ARE CALLING HER.
YOU KNOW, A RACIST.
HERE IS CONGRESSMAN RASHIDA TO
LEAD EXPLAINING THAT PELOSI IS A
PRESSING FREEDOM OF COLOR.
>> MORE PEOPLE LIKE US, PEOPLE
OF COLOR, HAVE BEEN MISSING IN
THE CHAMBER BECAUSE MOST OF US,
AND AYANNA PRESSLEY SAYS MORE
BEAUTIFULLY.
PEOPLE CLOSEST TO THE PAIN NEED
TO BE AT THE TABLE MAKING THESE
DECISIONS.
WE KNOW WHAT IT FEELS LIKE TO BE
DEHUMANIZED.
WE KNOW WHAT IT MEANS TO BE
BROWN AND BLACK IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO
NANCY PELOSI?
>> UPLIFT THE WOMEN, ESPECIALLY
THE WOMEN OF COLOR IN YOUR
CAUCUS THAT ARE OUT THERE
BECAUSE MORE PEOPLE LIKE US,
MORE PEOPLE LIKE ME THAT COME
OUT TO VOTE, WE WIN.
ALL OF US WIN.
>> Tucker: GIVE US POWER
BECAUSE OF OUR SKIN COLOR.
THAT'S THE ARGUMENT SHE'S MAKIN
MAKING.
ALEXANDRA KAISER CORTEZ MADE THE
SAME
THE
BY DEFINITION, IT'S A RACIST
PITCH.
EVERY BIT AS A WHITE CANDIDATE
MAKING THE SAME APPEAL AND MANY
DID MAKE THAT APPEAL UNDER JIM
CROW.
VOTE FOR ME BECAUSE OF MY RACE.
IT'S DISGUSTING.
BUT IT'S EVERYWHERE NOW AND
DEMOCRATS APPLAUD IT.
YESTERDAY, FOR EXAMPLE, FORMER
OBAMA SPOKESMAN TWEETED THAT HER
FACTION IS THE VISION AND MORAL
CENTER OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
A VIEW THAT IS WIDELY SHARED AND
BAD NEWS FOR PEOPLE LIKE
JOE BIDEN.
LIKE PELOSI, BIDEN HAS DEDICATED
HIS ENTIRE LIFE TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AS PELOSI,
BIDEN HAS DUTIFULLY MOVED LEFT.
HE HAS RUN ON FREE HEALTH CARE
FOR ILLEGAL ALIENS.
BUT NONE OF IT HAS BEEN ENOUGH.
PEOPLE LIKE JOE BIDEN ARE THE
PAST IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
LIKE SO MANY OTHERS, HE'S BEING
DENOUNCED, WAIT FOR IT, AS A
RACIST.
IT'S OVER FOR JOE BIDEN, A
BITTER AND BACK TO WHAT MIGHT'VE
BEEN A DECENT POLITICAL CAREER.
ONLY HE SEEMS TO BE BACK TO
THAT.
LAST NIGHT, BIDEN GROVELED ONE
LAST TIME IN A DOOMED EFFORT TO
SAVE HIMSELF.
>> SOMEHOW GIVE THE IMPRESSION
THAT PEOPLE WHO I SUCCESSFULLY
OPPOSED -- YES, I WAS.
I'M SORRY IF ANY OF YOU GAINED
THE MISCONCEPTION --
THAT'S WHY I CHOSE HERE IN
SOUTH CAROLINA AND SHOWS AN
AUDIENCE THAT IS MOST LIKELY
WOULD'VE BEEN OFFENDED BY
ANYTHING THAT WOULD'VE BEEN SAI
SAID.
>> Tucker: IT'S POINTLESS.
IT'S SPITTING IN THE WIN.
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, REMORSE IS A
SIGN OF WEAKNESS AND THE WEAKER
EATEN.
SHORTLY AFTER BIDEN SPOKE THOSE
WORDS, MICHELLE A
A KIND PERSON WOULD'VE SAID A
KIND WORD ABOUT HER OLD MAN SHOW
KIND WORD ABOUT HER OLD MAN SHO.
THAT'S NOT WHAT MICHELLE OBAMA
DID.
>> WHAT, IF ANYTHING, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO SAY ABOUT THE KABBALAH-I
LIKE TO SAY ABOUT THE KABBALAH-E
LIKE TO SAY ABOUT THE KABBALAH-N
LIKE TO SAY ABOUT THE KABBALAH-D
LIKE TO SAY ABOUT THE KABBALAH-S
LIKE TO SAY ABOUT THE KABBALAH-U
LIKE TO SAY ABOUT THE KABBALAH-?
DO YOU HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT
THAT?
>> I DO NOT.
MOVING ON --
VEHICLE I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
RODEO FAR TOO LONG.
NO COMMENT.
>> Tucker: MOVING ON.
JOE BIDEN NOT WORTH DEFENDING.
HE IS OVER.
LIKE THOMAS JEFFERSON, BETSY
ROSS, ALL KINDS OF OTHER PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT ABSOLUTELY ALIGNED
WITH THE MODERN WORLD LEFT.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY DEMANDS
ABSOLUTE PERFECT FIDELITY AT ALL
TIMES.
ANYONE WHO FAILS TO MEASURE UP
IS FINISHED FOREVER.
THAT ATTITUDE IS AN EFFECTIVE
WAY TO TERRIFY WEAK PEOPLE AND
KEEP PUBLIC FIGURES IN LINE, BUT
THE QUESTION ELECTORALLY IS WILL
IT WORK ON THE COUNTRY?
NORMAL AMERICANS KNOW THEY ARE
NOT RACIST.
THEY DON'T THINK THEIR NEIGHBORS
AND FRIENDS AREN'T RACIST
EITHER.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THAT.
THEY CARE ABOUT THEIR JOBS,
SAFETY, FAMILY, COUNTRY.
FOR YEARS, THEY WALKED IN
DESPAIR AS BOTH MAJOR PARTIES
DRIFTED AWAY FROM THOSE
CONCERNS.
THEY TOOK A CHANCE TO ELECT
DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE HE SEEMED